Carson has no limitations he's been
working with the guys all offseason and
we're looking forward to these these
next 10 practices with him hold him back
no no no I'm not gonna hold him back
that's Doug Peterson coach of the
Philadelphia Eagles talking about Carson
Wentz his availability for organized
team activities the last time we heard
from Peterson - the team's rookie
minicamp he was being very coy about
Wentz and almost made us wonder is he
not going to be available for OTAs but
he'll be back he's ready to go and look
that's fine with me the real question
Shareen will continue to be can Carson
Wentz stay healthy into the key weeks of
the season the key months of the season
will he be available to his team in
December will he revised his playing
style just enough so he doesn't get
himself injured again because this time
nick foles isn't going to be there to
bail out the Eagles the way he did each
of the last two years at some point once
has to show that he's going to be
available to his team from week one
through week 17 and into the playoffs
you know as much faith as as they have
in Carson Wentz he's never started a
playoff game never started a playoff
game that's hard to believe and he had
that MVP season a couple years ago
probably would have been MVP if not for
the injury guys are always better the
second year after an ACL injury I think
he's going to be better this year than
he was even last year but he as you said
he's got to stay healthy when they need
him most and he hasn't shown the ability
to do that yet so that's a big thing and
it's hard you're gonna have to change
your playing style a little but he can't
be running like he didn't get some ramps
when he tore that ACL you know it's an
interesting time in the NFC East you've
got two teams who have rookie
quarterbacks in Dwayne Hoskins and
Daniel Jones you got two teams with
established guys and dak Prescott and
Carson Wentz well what are the Cowboys
think of Wentz how much fear does he
strike in the heart of their defense
when it's time to face him you know he's
played really well against them has ten
touchdowns and one interception in five
games been really really good but the
Cowboys are three and two against them
so they don't fear Carson Wentz at this
point they think they can beat him they
still believe that
and they've done it more than 500%
obviously they've been able to beat him
with that three and two records so they
they think he's a really good
quarterback but they also think they
have ways they can beat him and they
have done that so far but wince as we
know if he plays like he does a couple
years ago
MVP level he's going to beat most teams
and the Eagles are gonna be really
really good I like the Eagles in the NFC
but it all comes down to can carson
wentz stay healthy long enough to get
them to the postseason and then win in
the postseason something he's never done
and I think the big difference last year
they didn't have the running game that
they had in 2017 it made it harder to
set up the RPO the run-pass option play
teams were just staying back on their
heels waiting for the pass to come out
of that motion when they would try to
set it up they I think too often and
this is one of Chris Simms big points
they get away from their game plan
because they get infatuated by the
things Carson Wentz can do and they
don't really adhere to that strategy and
that that you see that more likely to
adhere to it when Nick Falls is on the
field because I think it's too easy to
get caught up in Carson Wentz's very
special skillset that you're tempted to
just let him go out there and do his
thing and win the game yeah that's
exactly right and and well they were a
better team with Nick Foles at
quarterback than Carson Wentz at
quarterback and they've got to figure
out how to play the same way when they
have Carson Wentz on the field rather
than Nick Foles on the field and they
haven't figured that out yet would you
have kept Falls I think I would have I
would have tried to have kept him yes
he's just a really good quarterback and
I think he can be a Storting starting
quarterback a successful starting
quarterback in this league I understand
why they went with Carson Wentz but if
I'm Doug Peterson right now I'm really
nervous not having Nick Foles there and
let me be more specific would you have
tried to keep Falls and Wentz or would
you have kept Falls and traded Wentz I
would have tried to have kept both and
it would have been probably almost
impossible to do having to pay him as
much as they would have had to pay him
but I would have tried to keep both guys
yeah I just think that and and I said as
they as they
finally found the light switch and the
team turned it around and Nick Foles
pushed them toward another Super Bowl
berth that if they gave the Saints a run
for their money which they did that's
when you have to have the conversation
which guy are we better off with and
they have so much invested in Carson
Wentz it's hard to walk away from him
but you have guys to Super Bowl MVP you
have a guy that the TE 13 I mean and and
for all that the Eagles say about
empathy emotional intelligence and the
right relationships and you know you
have a guy in Nick Foles who understands
all that and I'm not so sure Carson
Wentz does I yeah i think that the front
office there's probably a lot more
nervous than they'll let on that they
kept the wrong guy
I had a scout tell me a couple days ago
that he thinks that Carson Wentz is
going to be one of the greatest
quarterbacks in NFL history and a Hall
of Famer so that in it's a scout
obviously from another team not the
Eagles and and so that made me more
confident and that Carson Wentz is gonna
be that guy that the Eagles think he's
going to be he's got to stay healthy
we've seen them with so many other
players either you can stay healthy or
you can't and if Wentz can't he can't
become one of the greatest of all time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports